[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno
bueno buenas tardes muchas gracias mi
nombre es ernesto el director del stand
de transatlánticos de folk chileno y qué
rico poder estar esta tarde con ustedes
aquí compartiendo con la música es
cierto de este lenguaje universal
cuando viajamos la gente siempre me dice
que fuerte que tiene el nuestro de viaja
con tu banda y tienes la música no debe
pasar por comunicar que es tan lindo
pero analicemos esa frase sea la música
es un lenguaje universal que todo lo
hemos oído alguna vez y así se nos ha
transmitido pero si no construimos un
poco la música es un lenguaje
y es tan universal o hay música que
pueden ser esas más universales que
otras o que no estancias porque si hago
un lenguaje a lo mejor de todo es el
lenguaje podríamos hablar del dialecto
por decirlo alguna forma porque por
ejemplo si fuera así tiene al lector se
hablan acá
y de qué forma se conocen esas de
electro afuera vamos a hacer un
ejercicio simple imaginemos una banda
que toca solamente música brasileña
donde no hay ningún rey
por ejemplo una matica
imaginémonos es una banda de música
cubana pero sin cubano o una banda de
música clásica de la india sin indios o
una cuenta de música celta sin nadie que
sea de irlanda y de su país
[Música]
de otras en el extranjero pero debemos
imaginémonos unas bandas
afuera solamente y nada más que música
chilena en donde no haya
[Música]
mis compañeros de música sobre todo la
música de por acá cerca
de países de la región cierto y parece
que están que están años donde nosotros
en términos de difusión afuera
por qué pasa eso y por qué no cambiarlo
esta es la pregunta que nos hicimos hace
6 años cuando esta banda por quién no
porque no hay más difusión de la música
es chilena pero por qué no hacer
nosotros algo al respecto
así fue como hace 4 años entre muchas
otras cosas que hicimos pero hace cuatro
años particular estuvimos en santiago de
compostela esta ciudad en galicia en
españa y es una ciudad cierto de
peregrinaje en donde llegan cientos de
peregrinos de todas partes del mundo
todos los días y nos reunimos durante
una semana 20 músicos de los cuales
habíamos solamente 3 chilenos el resto
eran todos igual extranjero en la
mayoría europeos trasatlántico esto
entonces tuvimos una semana solamente
aprendiendo música de un país
bueno entonces con el tiempo esas 20
personas que a través de esa frecuencia
se fueron como intentando conchi
desertor empezaron a venir hasta hasta
hasta ahora ya más de la mitad de esas
20 personas ya han venido a chile
santiago un tiempo y han estado con
nosotros han hecho residencias con
nosotros
porque porque en el fondo que de
oportunidades en ellas qué oportunidades
tiene cualquier persona del extranjero
de aprender música que les dé una
una estructura una estructura formal no
hay realmente universidades o escuelas
de música que tengan programas de música
chilena
y pueden acoger a extranjeros por lo
tanto no porque nosotros no somos una
academia pero somos una banda que tiene
entre nosotros y bailarines hay gente
que hace muchos estilos dentro de lo que
podemos decir música chilena porque no
va a cogerlo y hacer nosotros eso
surge entonces la pregunta estamos
realmente preparados como ciudad o qué
características deberíamos tener
nosotros acá en esta ciudad para poder
acoger a esas personas que vienen de
fuera que quieran aprender y disfrutar y
difundir nuestra cultura nuestra música
mi nombre es la nena soy cantante y
percusionista del ensamble
transatlántico y ahora me gustaría
plantearles una pregunta
qué es lo primero que se les viene a la
mente cuando piensan en una ciudad
probablemente estén pensando en
elementos de infraestructura como calles
plazas edificios etcétera sin embargo
para nosotros lo que realmente da
identidad y carácter a una ciudad son
las personas que viven en ella
la cultura es el elemento unificador que
permite el verdadero desarrollo de las
mismas
dentro de todos los aspectos culturales
uno de los más importantes para nosotros
es el imaginario audiovisual que uno
podría asociar a una determinada ciudad
por ejemplo si ustedes piensan en río de
janeiro probablemente van a pensar en el
carnaval en la samba en el bossa nova o
si piensan en buenos aires- van a pensar
en el tango en la música del bandoneón
en las librerías en los teatros
gracias al ensamble hemos podido conocer
ciudades de realidades muy contrastantes
por nombrar algunas les podría decir
nueva orleans nueva delhi londres praga
santiago compostela y el elemento en
común que hemos tenido en todas estas
visitas es que la recepción del público
ha sido excelente y así además la de los
músicos locales con los que hemos podido
compartir y esto se debe no sólo porque
no hemos dedicado a dar conciertos y
luego irnos como lo haría quizás un gran
artista también vemos nos hemos
preocupado de dar conciertos de dar
charlas talleres de conocer a las
personas que viven en esas ciudades
también e integrarlos a nuestros
espectáculos
y me recuerdo una vez que estábamos el
año pasado tocando en belo horizonte en
un centro cultural ubicado en una de las
favelas de esa ciudad
en un momento que no estábamos
interpretando uno de nuestros nuestros
temas llamado oro negro inspirado en la
música afro chilena del norte de nuestro
país estábamos súper concentrados
tratando de hacerlo lo mejor posible la
gente estaba pasándola súper bien
bailando y realmente miro un costado del
escenario y veo a una persona que
empieza a bailar breakdance pero unos
pasos así como de películas y vueltas en
el aire empezó a girar en el suelo y eso
no nos terminó de llenar de mucha
alegría y de mucha energía para
continuar tocando y finalizando nuestra
presentación nos pusimos a hablar con él
y él nos contó que era un profesor de
ese de ese centro cultural y que él se
dedicaba a trabajar con personas de alto
riesgo
él nos agradeció por haber darnos el
tiempo de ir a ese lugar tan alejado de
la ciudad por alejado de los puntos
turísticos de la misma
bueno eso fue uno de los conciertos más
emotivos que tuvimos durante esta gira
así que no sólo no hemos dedicado a
tocar también a sí mismo hemos recibido
muchas visitas a lo largo de nuestra
historia como ensamble
y todas estas personas nos han dejado no
solo su música y sus danzas sino que
también nos han inspirado a seguir
componiendo y a seguir viajando
un ejemplo de eso ha sido por nombrar
algunos países ha venido a gente de
finlandia de noruega de suecia de
dinamarca y todos estos sonidos nórdicos
mezclados con el salto de la tirana dio
por ganas y gracias a eso nació el tema
que viene a continuación que es sopa que
significa salto en sueco áspero lo
disfruté
[Aplausos]
[Música]
i
no no
[Música]
bueno
d
[Música]
[Aplausos]
cómo están mi nombre es concepción soy
chelista del ensamble y me gustaría que
hiciéramos un juego
para este juego usted tienen que usar
sus manos y tienen que usar sus dedos
quiero que hagan un marco con sus manos
así
eso y apunte en algún alguna parte del
escenario que les guste o alguna parte
de esta sala puede ser un instrumento un
rincón algo que está el reverso y lo
tienen
guárdelo porque lo vamos a usar después
cuando yo era niña tuve la oportunidad
de empezar a tocar cello y el cello
siempre lo relacione con la música docta
con la música clásica color que está con
los cuartetos de cuerda pero a medida
que fue pasando el tiempo me di cuenta
que habían grupos en otros países que
ocupaban el cello para otros estilos de
música por ejemplo me ocupaba en la
música folklórica en la música popular
en el jazz y empiezo a tener esta
curiosidad de por qué esto sucedía en
otras en otras ciudades y sentía que
quería que sucediera en esta ciudad
también en valparaíso
hace 6 años recibí una invitación para
participar de una agrupación de un
proyecto que tenía como objetivo hacer
una banda hacer un ensamble de música
folklórica quien invitaba a distintos
instrumentos a participar dentro de
ensayos para finalizar en un concierto
que fue en este mismo escenario
esa experiencia para mí fue como
reveladora porque cuando yo le quise
hacer este ejemplo a quien yo tenía
encasillado un poco en este marco era el
cello y la capacidad que tenía de poder
usar sus sonidos
quiero que busquen de nuevo lo que
habían apuntado quiero lo que habían
apuntado búsquelo
ahora abran eso
cambio la imagen
o simplemente se amplió cambio la
primera imagen que habían visto lo que
les gustaba cambio probablemente la
esencia no pero lo cierto bueno
eso es lo que pasó ese día el cello dejó
de estar simplemente encasillado en el
siglo de música docta y ahora empezó a
estar mucho más allá de sus fronteras
tuve el agrado y la bonita oportunidad
de poder participar en un encuentro de
música que si son suecia junto con él en
sant tuvimos una experiencia que también
nos marcó mucho porque en uno de los
temas que nosotros tenemos está basado
en un lenguaje o sea en el idioma que
tiene rapa nui y una de las chicas que
participó con nosotros era fecha una
cantante que da nueva zelanda ustedes
pueden decir como chile nueva zelanda
como que están un poco lejos bueno si le
dan la vuelta al mundo nueva zelanda que
haría como aquí cierto y quien está
entre medio y rapa nui nos dimos cuenta
en un ensayo que teníamos mucho más en
común de lo que pensábamos a pesar de
las distancias y que podíamos cantar la
canción juntas porque ella también
conocía el dialecto que hablan entraban
hoy
ahora me gustaría que se imaginen el
mundo como un círculo bueno es un
círculo pero ahora quiero que imaginen
como una paleta de colores donde tenemos
el verde el azul el amarillo pueden
pensar que estos colores son diferentes
cierto pero si vamos en degradé al final
no son tan distintos simplemente se van
mezclando se van sincronizando y nuestra
visión o lo que nosotros hemos intentado
como ensambles
es generar una ciudad crear una ciudad
que sincronice que sea sincronizada y
esa sincronía el motor de esa sincronía
es la interacción que existe entre las
personas de distintas ciudades
trabajando todos por un objetivo como
que es crear una ciudad que anide y que
respete la multiculturalidad y eso se
puede generar en cualquier espacio del
mundo en cualquier ciudad y porque la
multiculturalidad nos puede traer cosas
que son muy novedosas y cosas que tal
vez no nos podríamos imaginar hasta que
las viéramos o hasta que las
escucharemos lo que vamos a escuchar
ahora es una cumbia
pero esta es una cumbia india
[Música]
por eso el abanico
día a día
[Música]
muy barato
a ti
cultivada
[Música]
aquí
te hará
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero no
d
[Música]
ahora
uy
[Música]
nada
d
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]
ahora
en la gala
pero para mí
[Música]
para mí
la mordaza lo sabe
[Aplausos]
la guía para estudiar y sería la tiranía
[Música]
e
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah